rolling speed methyl mermans back to
high and I'm Cody Meltzer this is Tamra
just uh you should say Tamra just saw
and Cody also just saw really but dumbly
Jeff just just dumbly you know the good
ol phrase but that phrase is more
inventive than the entire film we just
saw
Tamra's never seen this week I say horse
garbage glue so we just had jigsaw jig
jig and it's an actual line from the
movie and one of the better ones the
best one other than when the detective
wakes up and is suddenly from New Jersey
and he's like what the protecta protecta
this was ass off him it was jigsaw it
was a soft it is very much in the vein
of sod had like the same shot the same
kind of like braiding the same lighting
you see the terms I just use someone
someone's learning listen if you like if
you likes the saw films and you still
want more if I guess this is for you
everything you have seen from the Saw
franchise to this point you've been like
yes more please thank you very much sir
then you're not watching this video
because you've already given up you've
already decided this is who I am as a
person but you know what more power to
you yeah I've recently just started
deciding like you know what I'm just
gonna eat cake and that's okay
like I'm just gonna eat a lot of cake if
you don't like this this is not gonna
change your mind
Bible ever and run for me well people
the lottery you can't run to get that
problem spoilers by the way it's a Saw
movie
half of the movie actually took place in
the past someone lost a limb
someone got eviscerated entirely and
someone got shot accidentally listen
there was pigs there was acid there was
Pig acid there were twists that you
could oh there were twists that you
literally could not see coming because
they gave you no information whatsoever
no buildup you mentioned Agatha Christie
it really just like grinding my gears
that we're watching it and there's like
the reference to and then there were
none and and I hated that that and then
there were four and then there were
three and we understand how counting
works thank you very much you were not
even close to this story to be fair
please considering how the movie was
written mm-hmm they may not know how
counting works so there's a character
whose face gets smashed against the side
of a pocket and we not we not only have
to see that face for the rest of the
movie and every single and every scene
somehow they've worked it into the
corner of every single scene for the
rest of the movie but they refer to him
as bucket head and then if someone
accidentally uses his real name they go
yeah bucket head just in case you've in
case of an audience member
fell asleep her amendment woke up and
was like wait who are they dog it's a
monkey in the audience did someone bring
their cat we should throw it in for them
we should really write this movie to
make sure that a tree that someone might
have brought into the theatre can keep
up you know rock with sunglasses left
behind I will be the first to say
sometimes I like a dumb
some guilty pleasures fine definitely
understand but this was it that it
didn't feel fun it just felt like is
going on right now is going on right now
is going on right now it was like a
b-movie that was really well produced
and done so it wasn't fun if someone
took an Ed Wood script and actually made
a really good movie but it was still an
Ed Wood script so it's still like this
makes no sense but it's everything else
is telling me that supposed to be a good
movie but it's not enjoyable whatsoever
I haven't seen a Saw movie since high
school and so years later really hit
home that jigsaw is like this internet
commenter oh I serve great and badass
justice wait no you can't do it back at
me no no no no no revenge is you can't
work on revenge but everyone who's ever
me up every single Protege that jigsaw
has had has completely not understood
the whole point cuz I don't think he
does either because it's kind of just
like half-assed thrown together
literally we have a scene rejects I was
like you can't you can't do it for
vengeance and and the guy had just
yelled at the guy he's about to kill
like bring my wife back yeah and he's
like because the guy even says no juice
I'll let people live like you're
supposed to like that's not how this
works the guy he's killing is explaining
the philosophy correctly do him like no
hardcore spoilers if you care these
shitty so there's two people they're
locked in like magnetic collars I love
well Louis he like confesses and it
doesn't work and then the lasers all
come down and his like neck explodes and
blood and he falls down and I'm like
that's not how lasers work the lasers
would have cut his face cuz they're here
and it would ya know and that goes so
it's almost like they turned off and
then turned on suddenly in the nation
that's not what happened we watch them
visually go down so then it cuts over to
the other guy and then the other guy
he's like confessing the laces and they
finally stop and he like is breathing
and he looks up and he sees the singes
and then he looks over and notices the
other guy doesn't have singes and then
and i'm like yeah and the other guys
gets up and it was fake and they show
the little blood packs and
and because he's the real killer in
order to have any suspense in this movie
that that guy actually died and we're
trying to figure this out the movie
expected you to realize that they are so
bad at making this movie that they would
have just forgotten that lasers would
cut his face off but they're making the
film and one guy's like do you think the
audience is gonna these are gonna know
that like lasers don't work like that
the guy's like one of the teachers I had
was a producer who was teaching
screenwriting and he told me that you
have to the film is a mass media for
film you need to get as many people into
the theater as possible which that is a
form of making film and if you want to
do that that's fine but you have two
choices as a creative person but I'm
saying art doesn't anything like
everybody makes film needs to be trying
to make art okay but you have two
choices when you're making film you can
either try to play to the height of your
audience or you can play the lowest
common denominator this movie not only
plays the lowest common denominator it
didn't stick around to hear what the
other option it was just like you can
either play the lowest um nominator or
now I'm gonna do that one wait but I had
other no no I'm good with that what the
thing is is this movie came out tonight
Thursday end of October stranger things
season 2 comes out tomorrow
like why the fuck would you go spend
money on jigsaw on saw 8 when you spin
what do we call it Oh boobie boobie stab
stab is what I why would you spend money
on boobie boobie stab stab 8 when you
can watch stranger things that season 2
if you want serial killers watch mind
hunter light which is also on niblet
mine hunters on Netflix it's great
though ol the cringe ease part about
mind hunter is watching Jonathan craft
try to be straight that's the it that's
it other than that it's a great show the
thing I'm most excited about is to wade
through the comments and find people
that are that are defending jigsaw yeah
my gonna wake up in manacles at some
point after this review
oh god 7 o'clock on a Thursday movie
it's Halloween weekend the theatre was
mostly empty if you can't get people out
to a horror movie franchise horror movie
on how
weekend at seven o'clock on a Thursday
you got a problem
I remember when like horror was the saw
franchise in the early 2000s when movies
died for a bit there and like if you
can't get people out to the theaters and
it makes your friendship Anabelle was
packed and it was only 90 minutes
I like assumed from the end that like
they're gonna make another one and that
this guy who took on the role of jigsaw
and his like weird assistant who likes
corpses are gonna team up I thought
they're gonna go on and make the next
one and it's like we don't we don't need
this wait no one wants us jigsaw has a
real bane problem every time they play a
recording from him I had to like lean
forward yeah because you can barely hear
what he's saying yeah you're a word I do
not recommend this movie except if you
know five people who have committed
horrible human atrocities then what you
do is you drug them you strap them and
do it you make the victim watch to the
end of the film and then they will have
changed their ways and that's it that's
the game the game is just surviving with
trying to claw your own eyes out that's
that's cruel
yeah but it's fair we don't need the saw
franchise we have 2017 I know life's
cruel you know what life is saw I don't
need this right now the Ragnarok so
we'll see you next week with that thank
you for watching and thank you for
watching and thank you for watching
thank you for watching they also just
saw bye
[Music]
you